[Music]
the community coming together for fallen
nevada highway patrol trooper micah may
he passed away yesterday at umc after
being hit during a pursuit on the 15
earlier this week joe mohler is live
outside the nhp headquarters near
decatur and sunset with more on how he's
being remembered
joe
people from all over the community and
different law enforcement agencies are
coming here to the nhp headquarters to
pay their respects i want to give you a
look this is
a trooper michael mae's patrol unit he's
using on tuesday you can see just these
flowers on top of here that people have
been bringing by and all the messages
that are just on the windows and the
side of the car i've seen ccs
ccsd police department henderson police
department all leading messages
on this car to remember micah may this
is the patrol unit may was using tuesday
when the pursuit happened people have
been leaving notes somewhat shreed
things like rest easy we have the watch
nhp announced the passing of the father
and husband late last night
trooper travis smacka says a vigil is in
the works for me
he worked with me for a few years on the
night shift he described
what kind of person he was
he is a quiet guardian
he was very humble person he
for instance i in 2014 he won the medal
of valor
yet in my entirety in my career i never
saw him wear the medal on his uniform
driving around las vegas it was easy to
spot the signs of the freeways honoring
me the flags at the headquarters here
are also at half staff the injured
police officers fund continues to
collect money
for the family's needs through the
funeral process now back out here live
you're taking another look at the patrol
unit outside of the headquarters just
the flowers and
the signatures and the notes that are
out here a fundraising event and a
candlelight vigil are in the works
they're still being planned the dates
and times are still being uh worked on
those will be announced here shortly as
soon as we learn that information we'll
be sure
to pass that along with you reporting
live outside the nhp headquarters joe
moore 8 news now